sorry I'm late no pump no problem
today's Molyneux and millennial right
yeah sure oh I'm just a really good show
today good
[Music]
so nothing but the ghetto take your
short steps one foot at a time and keep
my head low I never let go
cuz if I let go then I'll be flightless
I'm going it's a
[Music]
Oh get stopped for no reason
once I get down up be no reason it's
easy just wanna calm down please pause
seems like I said lay the law down now
so what you wanna do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the over-under because get
a better grip on deadlifting he knows
that he was producing with me in video
studio as always as Jared who is not gay
on today the free show so if you're
watching this on on the YouTube you're
not a mug club member you can leave your
comments or subscribe because don't cost
nothing you can follow him at Nike Jared
me at s Crowder on Twitter or again in
the youtube comments section or you can
send your hate mail I fulfill my legal
obligations drawing conclusions will be
good I mostly get hate mail
hey Gerald Morgan Jr at G Morgan Jr on
Twitter what's the one of the danger
we've got a lot of Malbec from
Washington sounds like a lot of man you
want to hold a great show great show
today we have we have stefan molyneux
huge and we have roman millennial of
them on the program today and we have a
lot of news to get to we also have a
today's sort of meet segment i guess
people have been saying you know you
can't you kind of hit one segment often
which we appreciate this a little more
in-depth as opposed to just hitting news
which thank you thank you person who I
just made up but today we'll talk about
the left and their recent anti science
tirades because that kind of wraps up
this whole week way weird week we did at
Google diversity issue then North Korea
it was almost refreshing to get away
from Trump Russia until like trust me
close down they're fixing up next week
it's going to be Trump Rush stuff right
well the FBI did raid a Paul Manafort
good old Paul man if we're all right in
other news face app is under fire well
again this time for their ethnic filters
that can make you look black Asian
Hispanic what could have possibly gone
wrong I mean I don't think I'm not one
to be offended or outraged but I don't
know how they didn't see this coming
appreciate a bunch of Russians up there
I'm sure that's people make sure that
show that again they actually release it
so you can do the president Trump Asian
is very believable I blow that fake
Clarence Thomas that's what it is but
the black Trump is looks like he's had
better days yeah it looks like he's had
better days and of course this people
were outraged there are people are
professionally outraged and a lot of
people were actually
particularly outraged that white people
are now able to get scholarships again
but some of their anger was quelled when
they found out that it makes them louder
in movie theaters so a lot of us thought
they were hacked this was news all over
social media history that went down
actually what happened was their servers
were crashed when a flood of Chinese men
instead of taking hopeful pictures of
their penis and black guys took pictures
of their FICO scores it just changes
your life especially when everything you
all your online applications they're all
dead I would have known yeah I love that
the presumption is that it's bad to be
one of these ethnicities though I mean
it seemed like do black people I know
what they look like are they unaware
well I don't I don't necessarily know
what they're what they're knows there's
no if it's a skin tone thing fine but I
think they've picked some features which
might be considered didn't they Don
beers and chai don't know isn't this
that will they have the giant tongues
with the dogs that's nuts snapchat
that's okay though okay moving on things
that are offensive Chelsea Manning is
now on the cover of Vogue magazines and
we got let's just move on like this is
going really well Walmart is taking heat
for a back-to-school sign and this is
one of those issues so you read this
headline yeah bring that back up so I
can Walmart markets guns it's
back-to-school items I said okay that's
fake news it's it's it's glorified no
it's actually worse if you take it in
context look at that display that
display is there it's not like an
accidental sigh Oh Bri the hero no which
which is why at first it would have
seemed like okay you see a clear-cut
case maybe of employee negligence yeah
but it it's pretty apparent that's not
the case when you see pictures surfacing
of their their anti-bullying campaign
yeah that's cool it seems like they're
going with a theme yeah I don't know how
you get it that off Walmart is now it
was a rifle in a backpack anyways it's
all the time
sorry but a second sorry Dean mmm but
cats in the cradle and the silver spoon
little boy just sitting on the moon when
you coming home when you coming out
Jared don't know when we'll get together
then
j-rod you know we'll have a good time
Dean you know some point it's just sad
yeah it is
Associated Press AP they wrote this
article how to know if your child is
transgender what experts say I got to
hear that's a real that's a real from AC
which actually and they it prompted a
follow-up article directed to children
how to tell if you should switch your
parents first question is are they
asking you if you're a [ __ ] when
you're wanting to play with fire trucks
oh my gosh how desperate all these these
sjw parents to have screwed up children
you gotta wonder at some point yeah I do
think I want an LGBTQ ai-5 it's so bad
could you see you see that that's not
you think it's an exaggeration people
used to say we were straw Manning when
we said LGBTQA AIP yeah someone sent us
a picture i don't know who it was on
twitter we tweeted back to me a test
crowded because I was looking for it I
couldn't find it it had the number two
in it it had the I swear to you the
number two in the LGBTQ a acronym these
people these parents are treating it
like catching pokémon but like if your
pokemons superpower is like unemployment
and suicide human fears fears were human
fears of being replaced by automation
and that we've talked about this is an
ongoing problems we were you know
President Trump says is going to bring a
lot of jobs back some of them can't be
brought back because of automation but
over these fears South Korea could be
the first country to implement a robot
tax this is an actual they claim it's
gonna offset unemployment and channel
revenue toward welfare programs have you
have you been reading this why don't
they just like let the employers create
more jobs no what does tax and death we
know what's best but Bill Gates proposed
this not long ago
yeah it's true yeah it was a something
about if a robot replaces a an employee
yeah like if they make $50,000 then we
should tax this tax the robot is if it
was a person right whatever the normal
tax would be for an employee he makes
$50,000 do you ever just wonder if
late-life Bill Gates could go back to
early life Bill Gates they support the
same thing you think early Bill Gates
would want a $50,000 robot tax bill
Gates to be like this sucks this really
sucks but big deal with the red tape we
give away enough free Windows 95 what
the hell's the difference of this planet
only the best
so robot.txt this is what they're gonna
be taxing robots in in a sign of citizen
protests all the robots of South Korea
dumped their soju into the Sea of Japan
now Rose you don't know people are
asking we don't have details while the
rates they're not official the
suggestions for the taxes are a 4% rate
for 4% tax rate for jobs loss to
automation 3% for carbon emissions and
then a 2% tax for the guys who keep
getting their dicks caught in the robot
sex stuff protections for those robots
they really do I do not think that that
is an actual robot sounds very well know
if you go to the wrong corner of
comic-con I bet you that's not too far
off probably that's far off at all Tokyo
Comic Cons right the [ __ ] Pikachu
getting it jumping into a pokeball as
that guy and so much of what's going on
here that's a South Korean mr. Johnson
oh there's a pokeball thing we also have
a Walking Dead panel you want to go see
that all right so it's been a through
line we'll talk about this with with
roaming Lonnie we'll talk about with
Stefan Stefan spoke with de Maury
actually the guy who
release the the Google memo the antlers
but there's better really important
through-line I think this week and so we
can go back to that that was a memo
released about the biological
differences between men and women this
was released at Google if you haven't
thought we have a ton of videos on but
Marley was dead to begin with okay that
happened and then there was outrage this
week Britain's youngest transgender
changed his her gender for the third
time and so what happened when people
said hey you know what maybe maybe we
need to revisit this maybe there's
something going on hate speech of course
right this is this has been so we have
Google hate speech this criticism of the
guy who changed I don't even I don't
know at this point guy or girl you can
let me know and then there's an article
from slate and you tell me because the
term anti signs has been thrown around
by the left so often it's lost all
meaning yeah so you tell me if this
could be misinterpreted that way from
slate titled stop ik waiting science
with truth so you know the left has
tried to have a corner on the right
being anti science yeah it for for a
long time science these are regressive
these are people who believe that the
earth was created in seven days and they
don't believe that you know Florida's
gone yet from climate reso they've you
know they've straw man conservatives
that being anti science for a long time
and it is interesting we talk about sort
of cultural shifts in the pendulum
swinging it swings so quickly right now
we were saying for a while remember we
were saying actually I think the the
left is is the the wing the umbrella of
the anti science party yeah yeah and
people said well no that's just that's
just hyperbolic this was maybe a year
two years ago and now they're creating
articles they're writing at Slate that
we shouldn't consider science truth and
they base it off of a bunch of straw man
so let me read some quotes from this
article she actually writes it's 2017
and people are still debating in
reference to the Google memo whether or
not women are intellectually inferior to
men and whether we are entitled to a
workplace that isn't toxic to people
simply based on their gender and sex let
us have slight about gender and sex come
on say yes
gender you mean sex now so
here's how you know you're about to read
a great scientific article when she
references a memo and says that things
were in the memo that that weren't in
the memo oh just counting up the memo
senators but I read it it didn't say
that
you're anti science no let's continue
because I think it can make a case here
she goes on to say it's 2017 and is to
some extent scientific literature still
supports a patriarchal view that ranks a
man's intellect above a woman's again
this is this is using the the Google
memo as a jumping-off point first off he
never argued that no really do you mean
figuratively no literal literally the
round never occurs now if you want to
get into that discussion about intellect
we've talked about the bell curve and
how men didn't occupy both sides of the
belt that's why overall IQ is higher for
men but it's not necessarily a fair
representation but men and women are
definitely designed differently yeah
intellectually that's another thing too
that we see all the time from the
left-right it's a matter men and women
are exactly the same a man can do
anything a woman can do and what we can
do anything a man can do they're
entirely interchangeable don't you say
any different okay by the way celebrate
diversity yeah it's so but if we do want
to have that argument yes there's a
women's division really in World Chess
Champion they can enter the men's
division I mean like if you look at
global rankings of all time it's
insignificant they Bears they barely
crack it and then there's a women's only
division why because we're wired
differently but let's continue see if
this this is kids too she goes under
right racial tax tsunamis conveniently
confirmed that enslaving African
American people will sorry after that
enslaving African this was before they
were african-american Screwjob it was a
perfectly reasonable behavior since as
Thomas Jefferson put it black people
were inferior to the whites in the
endowments of body and mind funny enough
this is the exact same argument this
woman and feminists like her use when
they justify killing her unborn babies
so it's not that far it is we haven't
changed so much now she's using these
straw men first off to vilify because
it's been all hands on deck to vilify
the Google memo yeah employee guy okay
and she's using it to try and shut down
dialogue coming from the right because
now the right kind
has a corner on science and on
Biological arguments as you've seen the
as the realm of cultural arguments and
so what are they trying to say just like
just like they tried to say before this
is hate speech now it's well hold on a
second science can science can is uh can
maybe be hate speech hold on I thought
science would no no because I wrote it
at Slate so here's we did some digging
into this writer and he's just you know
I don't know it might be like those
Native Americans who were on their
Native American reservations you know
but but then they wear Levi's the white
man makes me live like this no they
don't
to wear the Levi okay
so here's some history breathe better
than on earth
out of this woman's references a hundred
percent are white and eighty percent are
male okay
she chose exclusively male advisors
throughout her entire education the
undergraduates that she co supervise
have been 66 percent male and by the way
if just in case you're wondering a
regarding critical thinking this isn't
just this isn't just ad hominem for no
reasons because this person is actually
trying to alter the course of scientific
conversation and in the culture
she was actually duped by Ahmed the
clock boy so this is the woman who's now
making the argument regarding studies
that I'm done with her and this is
important I know you're just going to
say this is our this is ad homp no the
article we've refuted it allotted with
credit calm but personally okay this is
why because daily why I wrote about this
she claims she was gay in 2008 she
married a woman that year okay then she
divorced her and married a man in 2013
so all fit in her article she also goes
out but surely I'll just add this all up
she argues that a hint of irony that
science ok science which is not
necessarily truth has caused a
dangerously warm planet makes perfect
sense how'd you figure that one out
which method was that the Lapps lesbian
now married to a man method what is it
and see that's what daily why I wrote
about that how often lesbian women end
up having more sex with men than
straight women and getting pregnant more
often but if people argue that in many
answers let that lesbianism is more
by product of nurture than nature we've
talked about how homosexuality and Men
you've seen throughout history but
lesbianism at the rate that it is it
certainly seems to be more of a
byproduct of nurture sociological not
biological that's hate speech the nature
part is what you can see in the mirror
generally stopped it's hate speech
because science heat so if we argue that
man is it in Google we argue that men
and women are biologically different
that's hate speech why because science
there's no safe ground we argue that
it's impossible to biologically change
your sex your gender that's hate speech
well if we argue that unlike the
previous statements I just made which
are scientifically observable both past
and present that climate changed
doomsday alarmists are basing economy
crippling policy unless than entirely
reliable climate prediction models and
maybe maybe we should just slow down a
little bit well that's that's heretical
speech because science so we've switched
it this is a it's it's hate speech and
then it's hurt but when it comes it's if
that's you're a heretic it is entirely
about convenience and and that what Neil
deGrasse Tyson was talking about this on
Bill Maher they can't keep your own
arguments right he's talked about the
the beauty that science was
self-correcting that science was the
pursuit of truth there is a manual no I
don't believe that science necessarily
is all I certainly believe that science
can be politically motivated especially
if you look in the realm of grants if
you look in the ring you know the realm
of scholarships you look in the realm of
where people are going to get federal
funding to get national funding yeah of
course that can dictate sometimes and
you would maybe say it people who are
watching in the comments section Big Oil
you know we're paid by them we're paid
by the Koch brothers big oil and Big
Pharma apparently dictates our science
we will have zero scientific findings
that don't support BP personally
actually flew here today by the way yeah
I see seagulls in the Gulf covered in
Crisco typically yeah cuz I don't give
so it is it is an F they cannot keep
their arguments straight and this is
where we are seeing the left collapse
under its own weight we're seeing it
with Google when you look at Google
we'll talk about this was stefan
molyneux we have to get going where 50%
of people at Google actually didn't
think this was all that offensive yeah
but they don't want to speak out about
it when you look at people actually just
at large if you say hey what if I tell
you biological
men and women are different most people
agree it's not offensive when you look
at people in general if you say hey do
you think that you can biologically
change your sex most people don't think
so
now most people and they tend to be
right because so do most scientists but
it doesn't matter science doesn't matter
in this instance not because of funding
not because of grants not because of the
scientific method which is what we talk
about as conservatives that sought that
grants and funding can obviously alter
the course of the scientific method they
argue that science doesn't equate truth
because it could be offensive and here's
the problem with that is what is
offensive now and you see this from
Slate what is considered offensive there
used to be a standard it was something
that was deliberately meant to offend or
to harm somebody now it's just anything
that makes somebody feel bad about
themselves we'll talk more about it with
stefan molyneux coming up after this
[Music]
to the YouTube tutorial tension to get
more understand advertiser friendly
content which at the very least from the
channel of The Young Turks specifically
ana kasparian I don't think you are a
single-issue voter I don't think you do
I think I'm not here she goes on to
specify I'm not here for a [ __ ] hobby
okay okay Anna never for hobbled in
demanding equal treatment in the
platform level YouTube the misfit game
known as water
oh but world with the trigger and shame
on YouTube trying to that game
[Music]
greetings Auto of card of yours hopper
here you may have noticed my new phrase
Ogada monado is quite a shop calm where
you can get your suit
there's socialism is for figs on the
firearm shirt and does some really cool
clothes after one which one fits better
[Music]
oh right I did I did admit I made a wish
and I wish that we would have our next
guest back you can follow him on Twitter
you know over there but also his YouTube
channels youtube.com slash free domain
radio because it's not his name I don't
know if someone's sitting on his name
but stefan molyneux how are you sir I'm
well hey man I know that looks it looks
like a painting behind you but I assume
that's real you're out you're out in the
woods I am NOT in the studio at the
moment I am enjoying some of the natural
light that brings out my girlish
features so that is of course the plan
yes yes well actually light just brings
out any any bad features in this case
the light raking across my face all of a
sudden mr. Hyde comes out but you have a
book coming out relatively soon we'll
have you back on for an hour discuss it
so is this kind of your are you going
out are you sequestering yourself to it
in the final stages of literature you
know I mean the end of a book recording
the end of a book production it's
basically like trying to land a
helicopter into the side of a mountain
blindfolded in cyclone so yes I'm trying
to sort of really focus on what needs to
get done in the world to finish this up
so yeah I'm not at the studio at the
moment you know it's funny because not
Gyarados used to use it as an excuse he
would say it's finishing his book to go
to the super 8 and then we just found
him there with a noose and it just
evolved very quickly so Stefan you got
an acceptance moment no not well among
many not-so-great moments you got a
scoop with James am i pronouncing his
last incorrectly d'amour d'amour eh yeah
tomorrow tomorrow okay it's fine yeah
d'amour from google the man who actually
wrote this ain't a diversity manifesto
as the media has called it
what happened therein and why was he so
so quick to come on your program is he
is he a fan and and are there any new
developments I think I think he just
wanted something fair something that was
going to actually go into the ideas and
I you know I can't speak for him but I
would imagine that in his position he
might have some concerns that the
mainstream media might seek to
sensationalize and reduce the arguments
to a bunch of ad hominem so I think he
just wanted to talk with someone who was
going to give the actual intellectual
and scientific content of his argument
it's due
respect and airing and I think he found
that the alternative media was or at
least me was probably going to be a
better yeah there's gonna be a better
chance that it was gonna happen that way
yeah and it seems like it's been
well-received actually saw it my my
YouTube trending feed try something like
on corn I'm like this this guy it has to
be one of situations where Google was
like if you bury this one he was in your
trending feed to its it's in the real
trend see that would suggest that they
told us was eat it was organic
algorithms I would it is curated if it's
in mine and yours no they said trainers
for everybody training is not curated
apparently that's not what they told us
sorry okay we're trying to get to the
bottom of these Google algorithms
apparently they maybe have some ladies
unfit for tech in charge of them what do
you think what's it what's your opinion
on this because you've been a good
communicator on this issue I think we
both agree listen when it comes to
Facebook YouTube it's it's not about the
First Amendment but when we're talking
about freedom of speech we're talking
about that topic we're not just talking
about government intervention we are
talking also about this idea of self
censorship and specifically companies
being dishonest with their censorship
practices this seems as though Google
can fire whoever they want but they're
firing him for something they claim that
they would never do for his opinion is
that kind of what you've been presenting
is that what how James feels or does he
think it's just a wrongful termination
period well I think I mean in the
interview he said you know he loves
Google he's very enthusiastic about the
mission and you know who doesn't want as
much information to be available at
people's fingertips for them to research
and so on so I think that the concern is
that there's so much power in the hands
of these companies you know like way
back in the day you could pick up the
phone and you could crap about the phone
company and you could talk your politics
with your friends and the phone company
didn't do anything they didn't say well
we're gonna put you on the Super crackly
line or we're gonna put you on the line
which has seals mating in the background
so nobody can hear each other you know I
was trying to find that line never never
could
so it's unfunded somewhere you have to
enter a special code so I think the idea
that we used to just be able to have
conversations and not worry about the
content and how it would be transmitted
or how it would be viewed or how it
might be skewed now of course but the
amount of power that these companies
have it's very tempting I think when
you get people who have an agenda in
there and the agenda is not allowed for
the open discussion of ideas and I think
what is alarming people about this is
okay this is you know Google I'm sure
has this thing where they say hey if
you've got great ideas about how to make
the company better we value diversity of
opinion we value diversity of thought
where a scientific technical company we
value all of this information we value
this enthusiasm and he listened and you
know like most of its member youngt he
thought hey that's I'm sure that's what
they really want bringing back a dead
bird he thought wow I chewed a cat up
for you so you get gets to the juices
quicker right so so he listened like
most of us when we're young we we listen
to what people say they want and we
think that they're realistic right
I want a gentleman so I think that he
with great enthusiasm went in and said
you know I've got a way to make this
diversity thing work better let's start
with the science let's design things to
leverage gender strengths and and and
avoid weaknesses and so on a lot of this
stuff has come out of feminism as well
saying here's how we can balance work
and family here's how we can leverage
women's weakened strengths and so on so
he went out and he did this and I think
if you look at the ferocity with which
he was dealt with internally I think
people do have a concern that they may
not be objectivity and how Google
approaches data and that of course makes
people feel nervous about everything
else yeah and I do think it's important
we talk about this with joy Villa and I
think we'll probably talk about with
Roman millennial when the media it's a
perfect example of my god when we
started the show people thought CNN was
still actual news when you and I were
started you were guilty of it and you
were relatively conservative naturally
you just weren't as plugged in but when
you see them say anti diversity
manifesto says females unfit for tech
jobs it is so clearly a lie by omission
because he goes out of his way to stress
points as to where women would actually
have advantages over men and encourages
Google to place more value on these
points like cooperation in the workplace
there's our multitude of factors that he
lists there and we can't list them all
but people can go read them most sorry
okay so I know I know this kind of guy
cuz I worked in software I managed an
R&D department and and all of that he
had a problem to be solved right he's
like okay
how do we increase the proportion of
women in tech jobs
so like any engineer like any sort of
rational sensible person who maybe
doesn't always understand the heads and
Eddie's and flows of human backlash and
interaction he said okay a problem to be
solved and and according to the
diversity training that I take that
everybody wants to close this gap get
more women into tech more women in
management so he says ok well why aren't
there a lot now the answer of well it's
just sexism blah blah blah blah blah
that's not an answer doesn't really
solve anything I just you know it
castigates it blames it's a nagging kind
of answer it's a non-answer so he said
ok I want to close this gap I want to
get more women into tech so let's start
with the facts let's start with the
science and let's try and build an
environment to set us systems that's
going to facilitate Google reaching its
goal of getting more women into tech and
so what he did was innocently tried to
solve a problem boy baby slim rationally
allows he's been he's being asked
oriented you know he's an engineer but
excoriated for communicating like a man
what wouldn't it be great if it turns
out he's an engineer who's just on the
spectrum
I would like to think that people could
be rational and empirical with that
being artistic but here's something that
anything is important and that's a
really good point because we've talked
about this you look at John Oliver for
example his whole his bit on on the the
Border Patrol which is really hard for
us to rebut because there wasn't a lot
of information in there it was basically
logical fallacy using data up until 2012
not including new data but he basically
says ok let's let's boil it he doesn't
want a wall he doesn't like border
control border patrol so he doesn't
think more Border Patrol agents will
help
he believes in sanctuary cities Medicaid
there's really no solution there they
just saying this is bad that's bad it's
like the cool kids saying ha ha you suck
you you didn't do well but they haven't
tried anything here's a guy you see this
on the right a lot he's actually
offering solutions he's trying to be
productive as opposed to just saying
you're bad your ideas are bad it really
seemed like an earnest attempt to help
Google even if that's just opinion
that's how it came across which to me
tells me they don't want a discussion
the same reason that we've had to move
our interviews around you've been
incredibly accommodating not a
Ingle leftist would come on this show to
discuss it because they don't want to
talk about it well first of all I think
John Oliver does have a solution to the
solution to the problem of let's well
it's not enough people are voting
Democrats so let's bring a whole bunch
of people in from Mexico 80% plus of
whom are going to vote Democrat in the
long run intercourse the families are
going to vote Democrat so he is trying
to solve a problem it's just not the
problem he says he's trying to solve the
problem is well the Democrats are out of
power we we better get more people in
and vote Democrat and that's the goal so
everybody is trying to solve a problem
for some people are trying to do it on
the surface and some people are trying
to do it surreptitiously you're kind of
under the table so yeah this guy wanted
to solve a problem earnestly in good
faith using the best scientific data
available he went right solve the
problem and it's sort of like I don't
know going up to the early church and
saying hey I've solved the problem it's
not the earth that's at the center of
the solar system it's the Sun why am I
in the stocks why am I here now I really
I thought I was helping people this
doesn't make sense at all are we reading
the same there was a imagine if there
was a pill that could cure all of this
unconscious racism boom you take it and
and now there's no such thing well an
entire multi-billion dollar industry
bites the dust you know it's important
to recognize there are people with
entrenched interests who want to keep
social problems going it is where they
make their money it's the friction which
produces the spots of their income yeah
otherwise al Sharpton will be outside
rattling a tin cup and people wouldn't
give it to him because they think he'd
be using it to buy drugs probably right
- so we had a meeting with YouTube in
New York I remember they brought us out
and there were a lot of other
conservatives there and they did talk
about how they wanted to correct some
issues and then remember the
conversation kind of ended up moving on
and they asked us have you thought about
changing your content and I swear to you
and there's some very nice people there
a couple people there who
behind-the-scenes really want to help
but it but they're so terrified they're
like a beaten child
hey Satanists I've got a great idea
different God would that help you out
quite a bit so technically I don't
believe in God is it oh my god your
isn't the point but yes it really
whatever you think do you think about
changing your content they said well
with restricted mode we really say could
could a six-year-old wash it watch it
and that's when I said okay start
reading it here we go you know what what
was it was shame on who tried to run
game on it uh-huh
Oh Kyo ass up you'd show this to your
six-year-old you're like heart attack
listen that is part of leftist sex
education for six years I think that is
pretty much the textbook so that's
important to put in consideration this
goes along with the labeling thing too
right so I've got a video that's
happening at the moment which is my
interview with the guy from Google and a
bunch of the news outlets media outlets
have written about it and you know it's
like Gollum with the ring you know
because they they want to they want they
know the right thing to do is to present
the arguments and let the audience
decide for themselves they know that
that's the right thing to do that's the
responsible thing to do but they just
can't help themselves they have to put
stefan molyneux noted all right he'll
whatever it is gonna be they can't stop
themselves they can't they can't not
frame it they can't not give you the
words that are supposed to make you
think negatively of the person they
can't just say here's the arguments
here's the perspective here's the
sources here's the data decide for
yourself is like no we can't we have to
condition what it is that you're going
to say and I think that's a difference
you and I and the alternative media is
its fault I trust my audience I'll
present the arguments let them think for
themselves but the mainstream media they
can't resist having a frame that MAME
dr. Jordan Peterson alt-right are you
kidding me that's ridiculous but they
just can't help themselves it's and if
it's an opinion they don't like or an
argument they don't like they have to
frame it with some snarky negative
comment they just and and I think that's
a huge difference people pick up on that
a lot yeah I think that's a good point
speaking of problems okay so I'm
interesting your opinion here because
you're obviously a big big trump
supporter but you've been a longtime
pacifist
where are you on the North Korea issue
is that a quandary at all I'm a big fan
of self-defense so I'm not a pacifist
insofar as let the tank roll over you
and don't do anything so I'm being
random stuff depends you know those of
us who are old enough to have lived
through the hysteria regarding the
weapons of mass destruction under Saddam
Hussein I gotta tell you it's it's a
burn that doesn't heal yeah bad was a
significant like middle
destabilizing Europe collapsing kind of
burn so I'm very skeptical when I hear
Odin's weapons of mass destruction stuff
and going back to like Jimmy Carter and
Bill Clinton delivered a nuclear reactor
to the guy they said yeah go for it it's
gonna make the region so much more
peaceful of course that is never talked
about in the mainstream media but I you
know it's a very very tempting thing to
think well we're you march in there and
and you just go and replace the regime
and I think it would turn out different
than Iraq it's like the average IQ in
the Korean Peninsula is like one hundred
five hundred and six it's very very
different from the Middle East so there
is more of a chance you know I mean you
you drop nukes and and it is so much so
because of the brainwashing you know you
kind of remove IQ from any any portion
of the equation because everyone you
know they believe that actually Dear
Leader can read their thoughts I mean
it's crazy
look at look at Japan right second world
war like ridiculous amounts of
conventional weapons to nuclear bombs
and they turned relatively peaceful
Western democratic messaging capitalist
North Korea is not just the supposed
weapons of mass destruction but they
have massive amounts of conventional
military weaponry they have conventional
you know the howitzers and the guns and
all of the giant armaments that are
pointed at all of the American bases
just south of the border that is where
things could get really really
unpleasant and I do not like the idea of
America as the world's policeman it's a
local issue let the local you know
you've got Japan you've got China yeah
South Korea
maybe the American Air Force could do
something like take out their capacity
to to use air power or take out any
missile factories they could find but as
far as anything that goes on in the
ground I don't think America should have
anything to do with it I think America's
kind of shot its vault in its
credibility in various places of ever
since the Second World War and it's
really worked out well what if they what
if they really attack Guam is that at
that point do we go okay something has
to happen do we think okay here's here's
my petitioner I think that this this
misrepresentation and we did a timeline
on this yesterday and so this is in any
capacity Donald Trump's fault when you
go from 1994 2003 multiple instances of
them reneging on their deals testing
nuclear facilities no punishment no
sanctions what so the guy was
Lightning off like fourth of July with
Barack Obama so for the media to say
that it's Donald Trump's fault is very
irresponsible however I do think it's
almost kind of like a police officer who
isn't the best at de-escalating the
situation like Donald Trump if he does
plan on doing something keep it close to
the chest either do something or don't
but we don't want to get these guys
saber rattling you know and it's someone
that freaky and unstable don't tell them
if you're gonna do something just drop
the big one and walk away well I mean
anybody who's crazy and cornered it's
going to be highly dangerous right and
so I mean it is one of these things that
if there is solid intelligence that
something's going on if there's a way of
taking out that threat in a relatively
hands-off non boots on the ground kind
of way I could see a case being make for
that as a defensive maneuver but you
know keep pushing the guy keep pushing
the guy you may end up creating exactly
the kind of conflict that you claim you
want to avoid by cornering him and
giving him nowhere to go but you know
coming at you with everything he's got
yeah yeah and I really you know this guy
you do it really does come down to
sociological issues it comes down to
psychological issues with him this is a
guy who in order to convince people he
was a date he or his dad did said he got
11 holes in one in his first game of
golf like if of all the things today
driving at age three or something yeah
you know you can't get the kim
jeong-hoon haircut it's BAM the
eighty-five lesbian haircut is it man
it's bad I mean if you and if you look
at the way that they treat this is one
thing I will say though and I think
everyone can agree on when you have
moral relativist on the Left saying well
what makes us think that we're good and
they're bad because they punch women in
a stomach and internment camps until
they have abortions because they apps
they ripped children from their parents
and murder them they are the most cruel
regime you have ever seen if you read up
on what happens in those camps and it's
not the same as saying oh you know what
Donald Trump has someone from Goldman
Sachs in his cabinet
right no it is it is the I think the
most despotic dictatorial evil and
vicious regime and you know where the
Marxist who take ownership of it this
was founded as a communist country and
this is exactly where it's ended up so
can we just learn this lesson for once
in our damn history this is where
communism leads this is where expanding
state control over the economy of a
personal lives this is where it
all leads this is the end goal
concentration camps starvation a huge
Allegiant what is his father they like
plucked the the feathers of like 10,000
little fluffy birds to make his pillows
I mean it's completely psychotic its
sane evil dictatorial monstrous mass and
I want the Marxist to step up and say oh
yeah you know he's one of us this is
this all started with us
yeah well it's almost as bad a regime as
Google and I blame the evil the North
Koreans on religion as you know they are
the cause of all wars like we see yeah
devout Christians and/or Muslims in
North Koreans I don't know take your
pick at this point stefan molyneux hang
on just one last thing I thought the end
times guy was going to be a bit more
satanic and devilish looking than squat
fat Elvis I just and I see before me a
pale horse and beneath him a man was a
terminator one lesbian looking haircut
and hell yeah I know it really is it
really is what you expect the devil to
be charming or really scary this is like
kind of laughable stefan molyneux on to
it on youtube it's free domain radio get
that right free domain radio he has a
book coming out when it comes out we
will have him back for an hour Stefan
thank you and please everyone go watch
his interview with James de Maury thank
you so much for being here sir we
appreciate it
thanks my friend a great pleasure Rana
Millenial next
[Music]
if you or a loved one have suffered side
effects from been Shapiro's tumblr you
may be entitled to financial
compensation been Shapiro's double wall
insulated tumblr has been found to
increase the risk of rare cancers like
mesothelioma non-hodgkin lymphoma and
severe AIDS please don't wait if you
have mesothelioma non-hodgkin lymphoma
or severe AIDS as a direct result of
your subscription to the ben shapiro
show and is asbestos Laden tumblr
quickly join mud club at Lauder with
credit calm slash mud club for your free
information packet an annual membership
for $99 sixty nine for students veterans
our active military today hurry don't
wait as your life may depend on it
join today and louder with CARICOM /
Mudd Club
hey you feel good about yourself this
week seeing a guy get fired at Google
guess what that could be any one of us
and that's why we have mug club for the
daily content everyone there you get a
daily show you get morning grinders
every single day every single day every
single week why did I say every single
date that's not it's not false
advertising my brain is just I just have
a low IQ lotto with credit calm slash
short-term working memory is not that
great we almost got heat stroke
earlier today lateral credit I come
slash mug club it keeps everyone
employed and it allows us to not be
beholden to YouTube and here's one thing
I don't want you to just look at it and
say well you know what the five
something dollars a month that's $69
annually if your student veteran or
active military most people who watch us
on YouTube are students or a significant
amount I don't want you to say well you
know is it the five something for a mug
and I want you to think how important is
it for content like this not to go away
like guys at Google because that's
what's happening and that's why we're
we're joining ranks for their people
that's what we're bringing more people
on and the more you support the paid
content the more we're able to get free
content out there and just be a thorn in
their side lateral credit com slash mug
Club it's a hand - wonderful mug you
also actually do get a mug it doesn't it
doesn't travel as well as a Shapiro's
tumbler I'll give him that but it
doesn't stand up as well to a bat that
little house that little bastard is
tough but you know listen when you get
up in the morning you don't want to go
oh what is this thing what is this
coffee is it light roast tastes of Steel
you don't want steel in your mouth no
that's why you get porcelain go watch
people the art of cupping with tea and
coffee they only do it in ceramic or
porcelain atoms kind of calm slash mug
Club signup otherwise well maybe if you
don't sign up if you just hate good
beverages
[Music]
[Music]
that's the pong dance I think in my head
as a as a pong ball going with one
paddles I can see that no not ping pong
pong gosh
you don't know the Ramones you don't
know pong you don't you don't know
anything about the things sing pong gosh
you don't even know about Atari or pong
we have to educate him anyways well next
guess is young but she hopefully I think
she's she's more adept at history she
was a research assistant in universities
very prestigious so she must you know
our YouTube roaming millennial you can
follow her on Twitter there's her lower
third right there below us also roaming
mill because someone else must was must
have roaming millennial I guess miss
millennial as you're known here how are
you I'm good thanks so much for having
me and actually Twitter limits how long
your Twitter handle can be so everything
else is drawing millennial except
Twitter and it triggers me each time I
look at it I can imagine it would be
very triggering and by the way for
people out there yes she does she looks
like like Belle right now and that
initial scene abusing the beast when she
doesn't but I mean I mean cartoon Belle
not that Emma Watson caterpillar unibrow
fake though but you should stop these
this is folly for a lady
also in 1740s France apparently there
were black people popular there actually
surprisingly progressive yeah 1740s
France who marry who would know then
they turn into a bookcase they're like
they were the initial IKEA black person
turns into a bookcase that was a film
okay Roman millennial you uh I always
feel like I'm like share something what
I'm using a screening you were talking
about I know you've talked about this
you've tweeted about it set up for our
audience the controversy this week we've
been talking about Google and in Slate
and how science isn't true apparently
but you've been sort of centered on this
affirmative action case that the
controversy centered around Trump for
people who don't know set it up for them
sure so earlier last week it was
reported by the New York Times that they
had received a document from the
Department of Justice saying that they
were looking for people to handle a case
regarding racial discrimination in
college machines now after this story
got out a bunch of you know lefty
publications started trying to paint
this as the Trump administration going
after it formative action in general in
colleges to try and protect the white
race
you know like twice later is a cool clip
the quiet whites yes yes two days later
the Department of Justice themselves
actually let out that no this wasn't
across the board
targeting affirmative action policies
this is actually regarding one single
case that was actually put forward
during the Obama administration but they
had ignored so now Trump's you know
they're dealing with it now
right that was actually put forward by
asian-americans regarding Harvard's
racial discrimination so you know this
wasn't Trump's administration trying to
white knight the whites it was actually
asian-americans who a lot of people
don't know but they're actually the ones
who suffer most under formative action
try to get some fair treatment and some
justice regarding their admissions to
Harvard because there's a you know
there's a huge gap there the number of
Asian applicants who apply versus those
who are accepted yeah well there's
another example of President Obama
kickin the Asian can down the road for
Toronto nukes with North Korea know and
the slants the case the banned case so
hey you're you're like you're kind of
you're you're partially Asian but if I
look at you it's kind of like the Dean
Cain thing where I say I don't I don't
know
so did you face the kind of coffee to
refresh when you got your SAT scores did
you have to get you know several dozen
points above the average because you
were put in the Asian pool is it more
competitive or was it Canada so who
cares it's free well actually I went to
university in the United States and I
did well on the SATs
you know Asian pride and you know it's
funny because I'm actually when you look
at me a lot of people either think you
know I'm white maybe Italian you know I
get Hispanic sometimes I I never get
actually straight-up Asian and less
people are familiar with how your Asian
people look and they know people who are
mix themselves whatever but the thing is
my name is pretty Chinese I have an
English name and a Chinese first name
and a Chinese last name and people ask
me this all the time since you know I've
kind of talked about this problem before
I get a lot of Asian saying like hey I'm
about to apply should I actually mark
down that I'm agent now since I'm
biracial I usually just put other but
yeah I mean what happened in an Asian
pride you were talking about Harry
stagnation fried hash check Asian
expectation that's the bare minimum
don't tell nobody
hashtag representing the other just
big us don't want to get pigeonholed by
affirmative action policies yes
no but it's true if I were an Asian
applying to university right now or even
as a white person frankly I would you
know if it's possible just not answer
that question or say other because you
know it's come out they yes like if you
are Asian you are much much less likely
to be accepted if you are white you know
a little little better than Hispanics
slightly more and then you know if
you're an african-american unfortunately
regardless of how you do academically
it's kind of you know like Welcome Wagon
free to come yeah and it's not that I
don't want African Americans at college
it's just you know it's not fair to them
we've talked about that because they
have much higher dropout rates they're
much more likely to be in the bottom
you know tenth percentile of the class
and they struggle and it becomes really
stressful and you end up with a kid
dropping out of college as opposed to
going into a program where maybe he was
you know he was more appropriately
suited at the time or his scores you put
him you thrust him in with a group of
people who performed better than that
then he did that's the problem the
permit of action a lot of people haven't
haven't really read those statistics
it's sad that more people often end up
dropping out than completing college and
the LA the lots of Sheen's to decide did
they really believe in equal opportunity
or do they because they seem to push
equal outcome that's that's what they
really believe in and ironically that
creates inequality and opportunity for
people like miss chin over here I know
your name's not chin but it was just the
Asian name I could think of there's a
surprisingly good chance just you know
just roll the dice it's like Smith or
Silva in Brazil is like Smith so what's
going to happen with this with this case
because it was presented as you talked
about in the New York Times Oh Trump
trying to protect the heights for what
reason we don't know what what do you
think is really going to happen here
with with this case well the Supreme
Court has ruled several times that you
know affirmative action programs are
legal as long as they don't have racial
quotas or racial point systems but
colleges are allowed to take race into
account when deciding admissions along
with other factors right so it's not
likely that affirmative action it as a
whole like that's not going anywhere we
just have to deal with that in terms of
what's going to happen to Harvard
specifically there are some really I'm
sorry to say damning stats for Harvard I
think it's gonna be really hard for them
to argue that this wasn't targeted you
know I'm I think the case hasn't been
released fully and not to my knowledge
so I'm not exactly sure
kind of like what kind of outcome the
the coalition of Asian groups that have
like launched this complain are looking
for but I think this is great at the
very least right because I mean who
knows where this is gonna go but at the
very least this is bringing attention to
a problem that has existed for a long
time in the United States and you know
an economy where skilled labor including
but not limited to college degrees are
are an asset like universities choosing
students like you said who aren't gonna
finish it's actually harming the economy
and just you know saddling these
students who weren't prepared to be
there with tons of unnecessary dead
probably that's all's well it's a human
right so once we just declared a human
right and it's free you know Bernie will
be happy and then there's no more issue
then we just punted at the taxpayers for
another I don't know 18 trillion dollars
its engine that you bring us up because
we've talked about this it's kind of
rare that here what used to be I think
this generation of Asians now you get
some social justice leftist but for the
longest time you didn't really hear them
start marches or file a lot of suits
they kind of just went about their
business you know that's why they they
would flourish they'd be in the top
Business percentile they'd be often the
wealthiest people in the country they
just just filled up our universities
Asian Americans but now you're seeing a
lot more complaints you're seeing a lot
far more younger Asians who are
complaining about discrimination and
sort of you know future careers at
salon.com have you have you noticed that
being raised with a traditionally sort
of Asian family but but being among
younger Asians that um that a lot of
them suck yeah definitely well so you
know my father he grew up he grew up in
Hong Kong he came over to Canada in
college that's where he met my mom you
know and we moved back to Asia when I
was just a few months old but you know
coming back to the states I have a lot
of friends who are Chinese but if you
you know you actually listen to them
they're like mr. noodles right looks
Asian but not really and so I think in
these like later generations
you know first generation or you know
fresh off the boat who grins like my dad
who are Asian they're very um I don't
want to say like anti hippie job but
yeah anti hippie job focus on financial
stability stuff like that political
activism doesn't really lead to
financial stability but you have these
generations who have been in the United
States longer so they're kind of I think
adapting more to the culture of I don't
want to say complaining about things but
yeah you know being more politically
active being more civically minded
for better sometimes for worse like I
said like a lot of these Asians who are
younger our social justice workers for
you because I don't know if you've I
think it was the tipping point and I
think it's Gladwell where he talks about
how a lot of Asian immigrants
specifically Asians and Indians would
come over and they would open up shops
they'd be business owners and then they
wanted their children to be doctors or
to be lawyers and go to college now a
lot of them came over and didn't they
opened up businesses and made an
absolute ton of money and saved it to
send their kids to higher education so
now you have a generation of Asian
immigrants or sort of second generation
removed from Asian immigrants who are
being thrust into the university system
the indoctrination system and often
aren't making as much money as their
parents and are being saddled with debt
that's something a lot of people don't
know by the way it'll get worse if the
more we get socialized with healthcare
as your parents well know in Canada good
doctors leave but it's it's a twist of
irony there that they came here you know
we're not educated a lot of us we're
gonna open up shops bodegas family-run
businesses but they were entrepreneurial
and send their kids to college and some
of that spirit has been lost it was more
so discussing this economically in the
book but I wonder if that's also
happening
culturally well yeah definitely I mean
it's it's there's a marked difference
between the I guess work ethic of these
earlier generations and these later
generations like you said I mean even if
you look at the the curtain comes up
let's say you know Vietnamese immigrants
a lot of whom came over during you know
the war had absolutely nothing a lot of
them are still you know doing better
than the average white household and you
know this isn't due to education this is
just due to work ethic and I think you
know the brilliance of the American
Dream but I think you know these Asian
students who are right now going to
these you know universities expensive
degrees studying Gender Studies then you
know going to work at salon I think it
goes to show that college can't fix
everything right I mean a college degree
is great but it's not a magic degrees
it's not gonna magically create well if
you if you don't have that
entrepreneurial spirit entrepreneurial
spirit that hard hard work I think it's
still not gonna get you especially if
it's a science degree because as we know
science does not equate to truth Thank
You slate you've taught us a valuable
lesson today why I had a question cuz
you bring this up and it makes me think
I have some friend whose parents
emigrated from Laos and he kind of grew
up in a very like you said a very
conservative household very
entrepreneurial but it's kind of the
opposite for him is this someone who
served as the
Tommy from Baltimore sketch Jeffrey
Jeffrey mom from Baltimore yes go ahead
yeah so he kind of finds himself on the
opposite side where he sees the black
lives matter movement he sees the LGBTQ
AIP movement and kind of this and this a
decade of oppression Olympics they felt
feel a little left out there's like it
pushes in more toward conservatism
because he feels so screwed and left
behind by the rest of the rest of the
minority classes in America right now I
wonder if that's because it just comes
down to parents giving you a critical
thinking filter do you think that's a
big component to why you are the way you
are I mean personally I mean I can only
speak for from selfic from personal
experience but I want you see floral
blouse yes all of Laos no on behalf of
the ocean people if king of the hill
serves me right that is the correct
Eminem but yeah I mean I I've got to say
when I think of people ask me that all
the time like you know you didn't grow
up in the States you grew up in I mean I
I grew up in mainland China forebay
mainly Hong Kong but also mainland China
and Canada too I mean pretty socialist
if not straight-up communist places like
why do you think the way you do and I
got to say a lot of it comes down to my
parents and you know for a lot of these
immigrants I think there is there's a
struggle between you know wanting to
have your children assimilate into the
new culture but also give them the same
values you had in between wanting to
work your butt off to give them a good
future but also be able to spend the
amount of time that you need to to raise
them properly right so I don't think
there's one answer across all immigrant
populations but I think the Asian the
Asian population in general is a pretty
interesting one because you know if you
look at any stats social just stories
bring up to you know imply that there is
racial oppression of non-whites in the
United States Asians completely knock
any of those out of the water well then
they say well Asians who weren't
exploited the way what do you think
built the railroads shut up pretty
recent in American history okay listen
pivoting because we have to go let me
ask you you are not you I believe you
don't identify as a male I know that you
certainly do not have a penis from what
I've heard on the streets
here's my question to you do you find it
offensive based on the whole Google anti
diversity manifesto for someone to
suggest that a male might biologically
have advantages that you don't and that
you might have some advantages that he
does not on a scale from one to ten how
offensive is it
10 being extremely offensive 1 being I
don't care yes a solid 6.4 yeah but I
mean you know numbers are hard because
as a woman that's tricky it's ridiculous
obviously this is this is actual
evolutionary biology you know social
scientists also confirm this when you
look at like different distributions of
career choices saying an average is an
average doesn't mean it's going to apply
to every single person
I don't know maybe these women really do
need to study science more for them to
understand that limits this final
question actually injuring because you
were talking about being raised in
mainland China Canada the United States
then you have these these people at
Slate and salons saying oh the gender
difference it's entirely sociological
did you see consistent differences
between men and women across all the
cultures if you did is there one that
stands out specifically like did you see
okay so the clear example of where men
and women are different biologically
whether it's mainland China Canada or
the guard lots of context actually well
it was something that I did notice that
the United States was one of the most a
Western culture in general was one of
the most equitable I've ever seen right
I just traveling all over Asia just you
know the number of female executives for
example that I see the number of female
professors that I see and you know
that's obviously you know women in Hong
Kong attended we're not oppressed or
anything like that but I just you know
obviously the number of men who are CEOs
worldwide it is not coincidental right
and that looks at all different cultures
and I think you know for people to who
are making these allegations let's say
against the person who wrote the memo
for them to actually be so insular
looking only at the United States when
trying to refute these biological
aspects I think it shows a lack of
critical thinking right if you actually
cared about this you would like you said
look at all different cultures and I
think when you look at you know
different cultures everywhere there is a
pattern right you can you can't deny
that I think the United States is one of
the most equal places for opportunity
that I've ever seen yeah well the only
difference I would say in China they are
closer in size but in a twist turn of
life's fate the black widow female is
bigger and eats the male mate roaming
millennia on YouTube roaming millennial
thank you so much for for calling in
iosys she's by the way she's Hong Kong
honk-honk stayed up late early morning
where it is thank you so much left w
back soon okay great thanks so much for
having me and we'll wrap this up after
this looks as lovely lovely and you'd
said that thanks Jared
[Music]
is it 9 p.m. Eastern on weekday stop
asking stupid questions Josephine and it
doesn't mean you know a rare Destler she
did not mention by lwc time because you
know it sets me off for all these chicks
in 99 and on annually I get addressed
alone brother every damn day
Plus moaning riders must the entire
seokjin you light up and this most
beautiful of everything handy smooth I'm
a part of something why can't you
understand that
and what comes in case they rerun my
episode and I've been using as
evidencing an appeal
[Music]
hello louder will call the viewers
helper here don't forget the new
condition to the podcast on the go on
iTunes or SoundCloud on the audio you
can download it you can listen it
[Music]
[Music]
I'm the drowning dance Roman millennial
for millennia such a shame that she
didn't she didn't show herself for
months or years that still boggles my
mind today it is it is bizarre
maybe she's [ __ ] selfies [ __ ] um
it sounds worse when you say it because
of the enunciation for some reason that
was the drowning dance people have been
requesting their turn against this is
something we're just talking about this
about about earlier in the first segment
about offensive use to have a standard
now it's just whatever makes you feel
bad about yourself it's actually talking
on Glenn Beck show about this today you
know I I have this this nagging injury
and I haven't had a lot of time so I
haven't had time to go to the gym I
can't really lift weights because I have
a nagging injury my knee my shoulder
right now so well you know what I'm just
not gonna do nothing so just get in the
pool and do something and all those
problems yes oh there's got in the pool
and did something by the way if I know
you can get really dehydrated
in the pool without knowing because
you're swimming for you know 40 minutes
but unlike it you're not drinking water
so I'll be careful with that especially
in you know 95 degree heat and there
were these water weights at the fool
where I was going and I actually use
know you know that actually it felt
pretty good to move my shoulders and it
seemed to kind of help my rotator so I
went online on Amazon and looked at
water weights you know hey I feel good
about myself even though I can't really
do what I usually I'm doing something
and then I started reading the reviews
it was all like 97 year old women with
water aquatics glasses and they were
using the big I use the big well that's
not enough resistance and I felt bad
about myself and then I felt even worse
about myself when the internet had
tracked that I had read the reviews and
so I'll be going on other sites and I be
seeing ads for mesothelioma and Wilford
Brimley diabetes and it made me feel bad
about myself but no one was trying to
make me feel I'm not a 97 year old woman
I'd more like this is what the internet
thinks I am but no one was doing that on
purpose but the face app you could be
the face app you could be but you were
making a point earlier during the break
that it was an important one yeah well I
was saying it's funny how we talked so
much this week about the tech industry
we talked with Owen about the the
entertainment industry and the culture
of silencing that goes on there with
with any kind of opinions or ideologies
of dissent well now you're seeing that
as we just talked about for the first
time openly they're trying to transition
that to the scientific scientific used
to say we're the party of science but
now there's the
industry writers reporters are telling
the scientific community they need to
shut up yeah so I think there's a real
there's obviously a real problem with
the silencing culture of the left yeah
don't want information out there they
don't want anybody the ironically
diversity of opinion and thought and an
ideas I think there's also a really big
problem with the culture of cowardice
amongst conservatives to speak up
because you think about this the Google
think about the Google memo and the
polling 50% agreed that the James should
not have been fired where where are all
these people yeah at some point these
these a list actors the world who are
hiding in their in their cabins
conservative yeah somewhat we need these
people to step up and come out somebody
we know a lot of them to that's
unfortunate it's unfortunate yeah
obviously you've seen people on this
show you can do the math people haven't
necessarily been they've even come on
the show instead we can't necessarily
discuss politics yeah but clearly if
someone like Gary Sinise is coming on
the show and you see as you Lieutenant
Dan foundation where he entertains the
troops you could you can probably guess
where he lines up he just doesn't want
to be ugly politically and you can guess
any other celebrities we often have on
where they line up but it should there a
lot there are way way more who are in
the closet there's way more tit and it's
just they're lending their they're
giving way giannis culture of silencing
in this this this radical swing to the
left that we see and it's just it's like
what you're allowing and you're almost
at one point are we kind of guilty too
yeah well I don't think not allowing it
I don't think we are we now since I
certainly don't think we are I don't
think the been Shapiro's of the world or
I don't think Cain is Apollo or people
like Jim Norton we want to give credit
where credit's due yeah that's important
I think that I think that's a good point
and just think about this let me let me
draw a hypothetical scenario out for you
okay Google if 50 percent of those
people who didn't think it was that
offensive let's say it were
I don't just 25 let's say it were only
30 percent of people if they actually
said something if they actually hold on
we really don't think that's offensive
the guy wouldn't have been run out in a
rail the guy wouldn't have been fired
you think your goal is lose half their
employees yes no we wouldn't have the
problem with Google wouldn't have the
problem with YouTube wouldn't have the
problem with Facebook if people in the
entertainment entry when you look at
them when they're pulled individually
when you look at people behind closed
doors and I say him and I really do with
you on this if they spoke up we wouldn't
all have to mutter these things we
wouldn't all have to be
behind closed doors and I think it's
also you know this is a good example we
were at the YouTube conference
conference the meeting in New York now
the daily wired people the people who do
Prager you they were there they were
fantastic and and they were really kind
of allies when we started asking some
other comfortable questions but you and
I both know people there who were going
well and afterwards way to fill out a
form and so we haven't had any other
conservatives who have complained about
YouTube or our policies we haven't
gotten any on the forms member they said
that to us yeah
and there were at least 20 plus
conservative representatives there at
YouTube and that really pisses me off
it really does pissed me off when you
work for a think tank and you go out
there and say oh we're fighting the good
fight and you raise millions upon
millions of tens of millions of dollars
depending on the think tanks depending
on the nonprofit's that are out there
because that's also a big problem the
conservative movement is it's almost
entirely funded by nonprofits ironically
for people who consider themselves
capitalist they're also there are also
cowards when it comes out to taking
risks it's as far as people were
forwarding the conservative movement um
when you raise all this money and you
send to your donors and I notice because
I've worked with conservative nonprofits
and I've acted as a consultant to them
years ago and I said I'm never gonna do
it again because like banging my head
against a wall at some point I feel like
the kool-aid I try to run through a wall
only I just shattered instead of oh yeah
oh just oh no everything just broke
because that's like our team but like
like if it was me yeah exactly yeah and
you send these papers out to their
donors in these requests and they say
hey look look at all these things we
accomplished and they send out research
papers and they send out data that
they've collected or they send out maybe
that's a protest that they took part in
and the only reason they did it was so
they can send it out to people who fund
them more they're not actually looking
to ruffle feathers when it comes time to
actually just fill out a form with
YouTube or Facebook or Google just fill
out a form they don't do that let alone
go out of their way to make calls track
people down send emails and send these
people in positions of power maybe some
information that might be uncomfortable
they won't even fill out an automatic
form and like you some people who won't
stand up at a certain point you are
using and they hide under this this veil
of politeness and I think we say that
from the right and it is true because
you do want to be able to engage in
conversations you want to be decent
people but then you have people who
simply go out and try to virtue signal
and and this is the term that people
have used
where there shouldn't be you compromise
where there shouldn't become much you
can be polite and and still completely
disagree but that's another thing
conservatives and I think sometimes
we've had this cup we've kind of crossed
wires with Mark Duplass and even
sometimes Dave Rubin and then we agreed
finding common ground is not the same as
being civil to someone you can be civil
and you don't have to find any common
ground at all it's okay
you don't have to say well what if I
move in and you move in now no we don't
need to move in we don't necessarily we
don't need it we don't need to be what I
think about like like six and a half
month abortions what do you think about
like just like can you biologically
change your sets that you cut off one
ball I'm not moving to the center now I
don't need to tell you here you're an
you're an absolute [ __ ] idiot slash
you are a waste of oxygen because you
believe that but I can say no no no
balls cut off one ball no half a ball no
balls but thank you for stopping by and
we hide under this veil of politeness
with consumers and I think it's because
we generally are more polite we
generally are probably more I guess I
would say at least professional and
sometimes we allow politeness to act as
an excuse for cowardice at a certain
point you're no longer being polite when
you're not sending in the YouTube forms
when you're not speaking out against
Google but then you're muttering under
an anonymous name on reddit when you'll
send us an email or spend I know we have
a lot of people out there you'll send us
an email saying oh man you know I I
really wish I could show this in college
because they're teaching us in school
but how would you go about arguing it
how would you try and do it subtly but I
don't want to fail you know what at some
point at some point you're gonna have to
take a failing grade don't do it all the
time
at some point you might have to lose out
on some roles in the entertainment
industry at some point your scientific
thesis might be considered offensive to
someone in the lgbtq a a a P okay
community five salad ' and then number
two send that to me at s credit that was
an actual tweet at some point you simply
pointing out biology is going to be
offensive to somebody who's going to
call in sick because they don't like
that you presented their biology which
might lend itself to them being more
high-strung in the work environment and
calling in sick they took sick days at
Google because I said women don't handle
stress in the workplace
as well as men so they called in sick
because work was too stressful at some
point you're just gonna have to take a
big red F if you want to push it for and
here's the thing - this is why you don't
see it publicly we always so how is it
that it's so far left in the
entertainment industry in all of
journalism in all of academia you know
why yeah it tends to lend its up and
they've there have been proactive
movements for leftist to go in there
I'll give you that absolutely and people
have written about that Thomas Souls
written about that Ben Shapiro is
written about that as it relates to the
entertainment history you've heard some
celebrities come out and speak up
against it
but you know what that's only one part
of the equation leftists can only go in
and conquer it if you remain silent for
so long and and you don't see that
that's why there's this disconnect you
don't see it in the general populace the
general populace the purpose that elects
presidents you see them tired of
political correctness every dinner table
across the country on any given night
guess what you can see people saying no
no no that's not true well just in case
you speak out against the idea that you
can change your biological sex there's a
brother or a cousin or a sister saying
now I don't agree with that or there's
someone saying I find it really
offensive for you said man women are
different there's a dad saying don't be
a dumbass and smacking his son on the
back of the head this is a curry all
across the country the only place it's
not occurring is in positions of power
because of cowardice and if nothing else
this week I hope that you see when you
see what Google you see the
ramifications people lose their jobs
lives get destroyed we're really blessed
here because we've grown this we've
created something that's been profitable
enough for everyone to make a good
living and we're able to continue doing
this and if you join mug club we can
grow and employ more people and we can
we are really grateful we consider
ourselves very very fortunate but there
are a lot of other people out there who
don't have it and just like Sarah
Silverman these comedians who got by Amy
Schumer by being shot comics and they
closed the door behind them you can't be
a conservative get your way into power
by being quiet and then close the door
behind you when someone's being run out
at Google and 50% of you think it's
think it's wrong you need to say
something you can't be in entertainment
industry where James Cromwell comes out
and says you know what we need we need
to educate conservatives we need to put
out more propaganda effectively you
can't be a comedian and watch Chelsea
Handler say yeah we need
making it illegal for people to find
racist jokes funny at some point you're
no longer being polite you are just a
spineless and I would love to see more
people specifically in instances like
this the next time a Google incident
happens or whatever whatever develops
here from the Google situation that 50%
hey you know what how about this how
about 50% of that 50% speaks up we're
doing the best we can and I know a lot
of other people are out there but I know
that they could use some reinforcements
I know they could use some air support
and guess what right now the time is
right because you see it at the culture
at large you just don't see it in those
towers of power and I think the people
out there who are watching you know what
I'm talking about
I hope we see this come to fruition here
in the next couple of months because it
really could be the defining moment in
this country it's a winnable fight right
now it's a really winnable fight you
just have to stop being a coward buck up
[Music]